what's going on guys this is Rob and at
the end of this video you guys are gonna
have a perfect understanding of how like
Kane the Conqueror immortus how all that
stuff works together and like I said in
the previous video that we did this is
basically going to be the plot mostly to
Avengers Kane Dynasty although I would
argue Secret Wars may very well have
some hot points from this we won't fully
know until we get closer and more
information comes out but as we covered
in the previous video that what you had
were these time displaced Avengers that
have been brought together by Rick Jones
now remember while Rick Jones himself is
not the main focus of Avengers forever
the bigger Focus here is what Rick Jones
represents which is the destiny force
that in Marvel Comics over the years you
had situations where by whatever Manner
and whatever means Humanity would
somehow defy the odds and come out on
top with this kind of human just
Ingenuity or just this desire to win or
something along those lines and what
Marvel established really Kurt Busick
with Avengers forever is that it's not
simply that Humanity just really has the
desire to come out on top because
sometimes the desire to win just isn't
good enough a really good example of
this is look at the Philadelphia Eagles
they really wanted to win and they lost
the Super Bowl anyway so the thing about
this is that I probably should have said
that I've pissed off every single fan in
Philadelphia
[Laughter]
I'm sorry guys but I had to so here's
the thing the destiny force is kind of
this idea that different human beings
really the human race in general has a
kind of innate energy about them they
can sort of tap into and what we'll talk
about over the course of this is exactly
how that plays out but the long and
short is that this time displaced group
of Avengers has been kind of playing
like a cat and mouse game with a mortise
trying to find him trying to stop him
and immortus has always eluded them
virtually every step of the way because
he's a master of time and so once they
all consolidate their forces they make
the decision that instead of jumping
from one Universe to the next trying to
find immortus they head straight to his
base of operations and so when they get
there they basically get to What's
called the Nexus of time now for those
of you guys coming from X-Men the
Animated Series if you remember the
four-part episode Beyond Good and Evil
where apocalypse ends up in the Nexus of
reality and he had that custodian guy
who's red-haired he's really really
weird and then he turns into a guy who
looks like Doctor Strange at the end of
the at the end into the series that was
a mortise and this is where they were at
from here you can literally enter in and
out of any Universe in existence across
the whole Multiverse and so as they make
their way through here they find
themselves kind of caught in like
Penrose steps and different things like
that where it's really mind-boggling
because they walk up some stairs and
then find themselves walking upside down
or it looks like everybody else is
upside down it defies the laws of
physics by every standard of measurement
and so where it really kind of takes
them off guard what they find is that
they all all end up in their own
individual prisons of sorts now not
everybody's story is unique here but
what is unique is actually Captain
America coming across Nick Fury now this
is not the Nick Fury that you know and
again this is not really a Nick Fury per
se it's more of immortal is just kind of
toying with them to a degree you'll
probably see something like this in Kane
Dynasty right this is a very high
likelihood and I would even argue you'll
probably see something like this in
Quantum Mania not entirely sure that's
the case but I would would bet that
there's a possibility that this will
happen but the thing about this is that
this version of Nick Fury is the old
school version and the reason why
Captain America is familiar with Nick
Fury during this point in time is
because in Marvel Comics you basically
had Nick Fury and his Howling Commandos
now that was a comic book line that goes
way back to the 1970s it's been around
for a long long time but the idea with
Nick Fury is that before he became the
Agent of Shield that we're all familiar
with he was literally just a guy in the
military he was Sergeant Fury and what
ended up happening is that Sergeant Fury
and the Howling Commandos were tasked
with going to Germany and grabbing a
scientist who was developing a super
soldier serum that was of course Abraham
Erskine they successfully got him out of
Germany they extracted him from what was
basically Hydra they brought him here to
the states and then he gave the super
soldier serum to Steve Rogers so Nick
Fury has a very important history in
terms of Captain America becoming
Captain America but again at this point
in time when Steve Rogers with him
knowing who Nick Fury is it's because at
this point in time Nick Fury was a
soldier during World War II it's not
until you get to the 1960s that he
becomes an agent of shield now the
reason why he maintained his longevity
is because he ingested something called
The Infinity formula which basically
allowed him to stay youthful for an
exceedingly long amount of time
eventually he lost it in original sin
and then just became an old man or it
lost at some point along the line up to
Original Sin but of course Captain
America as we talked about in the
previous video this is a version of
Captain America that's plucked from his
own timeline or from the the Marvel
Universe at a time when Captain America
was becoming disillusioned and so that's
why this conversation between him and
Nick Fury fills Captain America with a
new level of resolve and a desire to
save the other members of The Avengers
and then go forward and confront
immortus now everybody else gets their
own kind of story lines to a degree and
they're interesting they're not really
overly important none of it really
matters the only one that does matter
here though is the events involving
Yellow Jacket because remember you've
got two versions of Hank Pym here you've
got the Hank Pym which I call Hank Pym
classic in Avengers forever he's one of
the founding members of The Avengers
with Jana Van Dyne then you've got crazy
Hank Pym he's the one that like lost his
mind and he was going through all these
existential crises just all that kind of
stuff right just like the nuts Hank Pimp
Like that's what we're talking about and
so it's one of those cool moments where
once the team basically reconsolidates
they get back to their normal selves you
end up finding the classic Hank Pym
realizing that he'll eventually become
the crazy Hank Pym ends up allying
himself with a mortise and the reason
why is because amort has proposed this
idea that if he allies himself with
immortus that he can actually ensure a
timeline comes to existence where Hing
Pim doesn't go crazy he doesn't end up
becoming his just kind of nuts
existential madman self and so in effect
one of the members of The Avengers team
have now defected to the side of
immortus and so following this we we get
a bit of an exposition here and the
reason why is because the Avengers start
to realize that one of the space
Phantoms is masquerading as one of their
own and when The Jig Is up right when
the when the ruse is pulled that you
basically have the space Phantom this
starts offering this huge dump of
information now this is one of the
reasons why this story is so incredibly
important because up to this point in
Marvel Comics all we knew is that Kane
to conquer was going to become a mortise
but we didn't know how we didn't really
know there were no real dots connecting
that and what few dots we got
contradicted everything else right it
was just sort of weird the way it played
out but the thing about this and what we
find out is seemingly almost every major
issue that the Avengers have run into
with immortus has all been done for a
very particular purpose one of the first
things we learned though is about the
space Phantoms themselves the space
Phantom initially was just a singular
being who was out there that the
Avengers fought at one point in time and
was kind of a Prelude to like the
arrival of immortus Tempest and that
kind of stuff what we're told here is
much like what you saw in the Loki TV
show where you have those individual who
are quote unquote pruned by the time
variance Authority and they end up
basically at the very end of time on
that planet and they're ultimately
consumed this is similar to that and in
fact the show borrowed from that the way
this works is that by whatever Manner
and whatever means individuals will end
up in the realm of limbo they'll end up
in basically the place where immortus
resides sometimes they stumble into it
sometimes they cast magic not knowing
what they're doing they pass through the
portal they end up here sometimes they
get sent here by other people right just
whisked away to some Dimension somewhere
and that Dimension ends up being limbo
but whatever the case happens to be over
time every single one of these people
who were locked away here will
eventually lose themselves they'll
forget who they were and their own world
will forget who they were and in losing
their identity they will ultimately
become space Phantoms and that basically
explains where they come from and why
there's so many of them and so when this
huge Revelation is given to us what He
also says is that all these different
conflicts clicks where immortus has
shown up here has all been done for One
Singular purpose The Avengers facing off
against the mortis immortus showing up
and challenging different superheroes or
initiating events it's all been done for
a singular purpose and this has been
done at the behest of the timekeepers
that over the course of his existence
when ever Kang became immortus
eventually he was met by the arrival of
the timekeepers and instead of him being
lost to the effects of limbo much in the
same way that the space Phantoms were
due to the intervention of the
timekeepers and their ability to kind of
Safeguard and protect immortus that what
immortus would do is he would basically
prune timelines based on what the
timekeepers wanted so again referencing
the Loki TV show that's where these
similarities come from now their
motivation will be explained over the
course of this and is actually pretty
nefarious but that will be explained as
time goes on the long and short of this
though is that as far as the timekeepers
are concerned he humanity is the
greatest threat that exists in the
Multiverse and the reason for this is
that at the moment right at the moment
that this comic is being written that
Humanity just has superheroes the
Fantastic Four the X-Men different
people like that that the most powerful
beings usually are confined to teams and
they protect Humanity from whatever
threats exist but because of the nature
of the destiny Force eventually Humanity
as a whole will achieve extreme levels
of power incredible levels of power
they'll be able to tap into what form
that power will take isn't fully fleshed
out here but what is fleshed out is that
with this new level of power Humanity
will take to the stars and when that
happens they'll start conquering entire
worlds and so on and basically in all
these different universes across the
Multiverse Humanity ends up becoming a
kind of conquering race and so that's
why when we did the last video at the
beginning of the story we covered that
little segment where basically The
Avengers showed up and conquered an
entire world because that's what happens
across multiple realities and so in
order to keep that from happening or at
least on the on the surface in order to
keep that from happening the timekeepers
brought in immortus to get rid of the
timelines where that could potentially
be the case by removing circumstances
where Humanity would take to the Stars
yes different superhero teams on earth
have gone into space but they never stay
there they always come back to earth
because the manipulation of immortus
behind the scenes was basically trying
to keep humans confined to Earth so that
if they never leave Earth they never
become a threat to the rest of the
universe the idea is they would never be
able to channel the destiny force in an
effective way and so again it's a it's a
really cruel Revelation here because it
just talks about these extreme
manipulations and they're far-reaching
right it's one of the reasons why his
character is so significant at Marvel
but it also really shows how in just how
immensely powerful he is and that's
something that I hope you take away from
this because if the Marvel Cinematic
Universe handles Kane the Conqueror
right he'll be ridiculously op not by
just physical strength or the ability to
shoot energy or something like that but
because how do you stop a guy who can
prevent you from being born or who could
have your have some situation where like
you're Switched at Birth and you're
raised by a different family and instead
of becoming an Avenger like Captain
America becoming an Avenger Captain
America is the guy who works in a tax
office somewhere right just things like
that right being able to alter the
entire history of a universe or even
just using the forever Crystal wipe an
entire universe out of existence right
literally just blink it out just with a
with just like that it ceases to exist
because one of the things to remember is
that in Marvel Comics you have Branch
universe theory that alternate realities
come into existence because something
that happened in the main Marvel
Universe happened differently right a
really good example of this is in secret
Wars in 1984. Peter Parker gets the
Venom symbiote for the very first time
it's not called the Venom symbiote but
it becomes the Venom symbiote so there's
an alternate reality out there where
Peter never lost it and in fact there is
a story where that happens and the
Symbiote basically just consumes them
there's a point where the Symbiotes
blown off of his body and it's just
literally bones like it had literally
eaten his physical body and so it's just
the Symbiote walking around bones it's
pretty gruesome and it's pretty messed
up but that's an alternate reality now
right what if this one thing had
happened different now it's an alternate
universe so all in mortis has to do is
go back to that moment when things
deviated when that Branch happened and
keep that event from taking place or
just wipe the universe out entirely
there's any number of ways that he can
pull that off but that's what he's been
doing over the course of time is working
for the timekeepers by basically pruning
entire timelines but the problem with
this is that seemingly The Avengers
always end up finding a way to train or
to to transition into space and Humanity
seems to always find a way to attain the
destiny force and so what ends up
happening is that with immortus and
yellow jacket working together
Yellowjackets subdues The Avengers and
then when they wake up they base
basically find themselves in an
alternate reality and that's one of the
things to know when you're facing off
against someone like immortus that in
you know instead of like it being a
normal circumstance like here right you
get kidnapped and they drop you off in a
field somewhere that you get kidnapped
and you get dropped off three universes
over right that's what you end up with
that's why I'm messing with somebody
like like immortus or even Kang it's
such a dangerous thing because you could
just be thrown into the Multiverse and
you'll never make your way back you'll
never get back to your home Universe
it's like sliders right it's like that
TV show sliders but when the Avengers
wake up they kind of wake up in this
different reality where again you have
these kind of Ironclad Avengers who
operate as like conquerors but what ends
up happening and it's a quick
realization these you know kind of uh
nights nightly Avengers if you want to
call them that they don't see the real
Avengers as actual Avengers they see
them as the Guardians of the Galaxy now
here's the thing in Marvel Comics kind
of a quick aside here in Marvel Comics
The Guardians of the Galaxy as you know
them now which is like Peter Quill and
like Rocket Raccoon and Groot and Gamora
and all those guys that's not the
original Guardians the original
Guardians of the Galaxy were called the
Guardians of the Galaxy 3000. they
literally came from the 31st Century but
this is that team right this is like the
original Guardians of the Galaxy 3000
team they were at least they're seen as
Freedom Fighters here individuals who
are fighting against the Conquering
nature of the Avengers and it's why
they're immediately attacked now in the
midst of all this basically Hank Pym or
at least yellowjacket Hank Pym steps in
and basically helps them to overcome
these enemies and then reveals to them
that the reason why they appear
different was because of things called
Limbo bugs which basically kind of cast
an illusion and make things seem
different than they actually are but the
important thing here is that this allows
the Avengers to be taken prisoner and to
actually be brought directly in front of
the timekeepers themselves by immortus
and this is a de facto trial that's
really all this is that is the time
Keepers speaking directly to the
Avengers as basically immortus watches
on and this is when we get this really
really cool Revelation here right this
really cool explanation there is a bit
of discussion here in the sense that
what you had was being called he who
remains at the very end of time and in
order to ensure the preservation of the
time stream he created the timekeepers
in order to ensure that time flowed as
it was supposed to that all reality
functioned the way it was supposed to
and the the coming of the new universe
right because that Universe was
effectively ending but even the
timekeepers themselves appear to be
nefarious foes and the reason for this
is because over the course of this trial
and in this conversation that they have
what the timekeepers say is exactly what
we just talked about they attached
immortus with wiping out different
timelines where the Avengers would
transition to the Stars harness the
power of the destiny force and become
conquerors and so in realizing this what
they decide is to basically Purge any
and all of those realities that exist
out there and in fact every every world
or every version of Earth across the
Multiverse will effectively be put on
lockdown where humans would never be
allowed to leave Earth they would be
forced to stay there now again the
question of the Avengers is but like why
though because at the end of the day
like we as The Avengers like we're good
guys we're superheroes we would never
become villains and there really isn't
even anything for us to for you to worry
about when it comes to us because there
are groups and individuals out there
that are more powerful than us on Earth
but the response to the timekeepers is
you underestimate your level of power
right think about it of all the planets
that exist in any one universe and
particularly in your main Marvel
Universe Earth is the only world that
was able to Stave off Galactus that was
able to hold Galactus fact and in fact
send him running in fear when like Reed
Richards ran up on him brandishing the
ultimate nullifier right like Humanity
has managed to hold off the Judgment of
the celestials it's one of these things
where they're basically making this
argument humanity is way any more
powerful than you think it is and it's
only a matter of time before this
Destiny force will be harnessed by
humanity and they'll basically destroy
everything in existence or at least
conquer entire universes and so when the
questions asked by Captain America how
in how many universes does this take
place and the response of the
timekeepers is it happens 42 percent of
the time and that's when The Avengers
are like that's stupid man so like you
literally want to punish the entirety of
humanity across the Multiverse confining
us to Earth so we can never leave over
the fact that only 42 percent of the
time we become Universal conquerors and
even if your job is to do nothing more
than observe then what does it matter
because this is the natural flow of
things arguably it's how it's supposed
to happen so that's when they call the
bluff of the timekeepers and their
argument is it has nothing to do with
Justice it has nothing to do with
maintaining the flow of time or anything
like that this is you just trying to
ensure that nobody gets in your way you
want to be the soul beings capable of
like ruling the entire universe that's
really all you want to do it's a mad
grab for power and you're masquerading
as a PR as a group of people trying to
do the right thing trying to ensure that
different universes across the
Multiverse all stay protected yeah we
call your bluff and that's not gonna
happen now the other part of this and
the big Revelation that goes on here is
yellowjacket classic Hank Pym that what
had happened here is that him working
alongside immortus it was not a ruse he
really intended to betray The Avengers
but when he realized what was going on
with him Waters of the timekeepers which
is to say that the 42 percent right
those universes that exist out there
where Humanity would end up becoming
conquerors that the timekeepers wanted
to wipe those universes out that the
desire or at least the intention of of
uh of yellowjacket right classic hang
Pym what's the turn against both the
mortis and the timekeepers one that's
the reason why he was we freed the
Avengers in the first place and two
that's why he called for backup when he
real realize what was happening he sent
out an SOS now this SOS comes in two
forms the first is Rick Jones and Kane
the Conqueror alongside the Supreme
intelligence now here's the cool thing
about this Kane the Conqueror arriving
on the scene is no small thing because
King is inevitably destined to become
immortus but what you're talking about
here are two guys who are able to
manipulate the timeline now which one is
more powerful is one of the most debated
things in Marvel Comics like that debate
rages across the fandom it just goes on
and on and on and on and I don't think
we'll ever definitively get an answer to
that unless Marvel creates one but the
reality here is that with Kane the
conquer stepping in The Avengers freed
Rick Jones being able to harness the
power of the destiny force and the
Supreme intelligence just sitting there
as a giant head in a jar watching it all
in full that the uh the timekeepers
basically summon their own teams and so
what you end up getting is basically the
quote unquote evil Avengers from across
the time stream all these different evil
Avengers that you see or that we have
seen showing up here and facing off
against the good Avengers and so in
response to that the good Avengers
summoned their own backup which is
basically every version or every every
avenger that exists in the Multiverse
literally coming in right every single
good guy showing up to face off every
single bad guy and that's why I say this
is probably what you're going to see in
King Dynasty that in King Dynasty and
Secret Wars you're going to see a whole
host of evil Avengers it's gonna be
amazing right it's gonna be ridiculously
cool just like multi like Avengers from
the Multiverse all fighting against each
other right just a giant thing that's
why it's gonna be called secret War
because it's going to happen all the way
out there and the average person is
going to have no idea that it's taking
place but in the midst of all this
immortus realizing that what the
timekeepers would do is not only
eradicate The Avengers who were here but
even go so far as to just prune entire
universes can't tolerate it anymore he
can't side with this anymore so in fact
he even he ends up taking the crystal
the forever Crystal and tries to hide it
from the timekeepers Turning against
them refusing to let them destroy the
Avengers and a lot of this is because
with immortus having watched The
Avengers for so long having guided their
actions he almost sees them as his own
children but he almost feels very much
like a parent he's come to care about
them and come to love them even though
what he was doing was a manipulation
behind the scenes and so when he turns
against the timekeepers the time Keepers
eradicate him on the spot they literally
destroy him and like that's basically it
and so in the midst of this giant
conflict between all these different
Avengers ultimately the good guys
effectively come out on top now it's not
for the time Keepers stepping in and
like freezing everything in place but
with Kane the Conqueror being a guy who
is literally protected from the time
stream and the impact of time remember
you can't freeze Kane the Conqueror in
place in time it doesn't work that way
he's a master of Tom all he has to do is
just kind of like not need to just not
be a affected by it because at all times
his suit of armor allows him to operate
in flush right it allows him to exist
kind of outside the current effects of
time and so this is the reason why even
when the the timekeepers basically frees
everybody in place by manipulating time
Kane the Conqueror is not affected but
realizing the the power of King and
realizing that he's like the last
missing piece the last person that can
manipulate the time stream and truly
stand in their way the timekeepers try
to basically turn Kang into a mortise
but what ends up happening is that with
that version of immortus having been
destroyed this is where the cleanup Duty
comes into play that what Marvel does
now is they say actually immortus as he
exists from this point going forward is
the result of the time Keepers trying to
turn Kang into a mortise while literally
speeding up his Evolution and then in
turn came the Conqueror resisting and so
what is what's really told here is that
in this effort to transform Kang that
you end up getting this it's almost kind
of squelching sound right this tearing
sound like flesh is ripped and came to
conqueror himself remains his normal
self the issue with this is that even
though the timekeepers are trying to use
this forever Crystal to literally
obliterate entire timelines by using its
energy to fire a cannon that because
they're so weakened now after having
tried to force Kang into becoming
immortus that ultimately King takes that
moment to kill the timekeepers he
literally eradicates them on the spot
and so once the battle is concluded
Captain America who now has possession
of the crystal ends up destroying it and
that witness destroyed everybody starts
blinking back to their own individual
timelines right they start going back to
where they're supposed to be and so you
have this really really interesting
moment here where you basically have the
rise of the new immortus right literally
this immortus pops up here as having
been kind of pulled away from Kane the
conquer so in essence King and immortus
are the exact same person that's the
reason why now in Marvel Comics you
don't really see much discussion about
immortus being the person that Kang will
become instead it's immortus referring
to Kang as being a mortise and it's Kang
referring to immortus as being Kang
because literally they're ripped out of
the same person because literally what
had happened here is in an attempt to
turn Kang into a mortise Kang resisted
and so that immortus aspect of him was
pulled away it's not that dissimilar to
Eve being made from the Flesh of Adam
right they're very similar things in
that way but the long and short of this
is that with that Crystal destroyed
everybody blinking back to their normal
points in time what we're told here is
that the crystal represents a concept it
represents the idea of being able to
manipulate and control time and so what
the crystal represents can never truly
be destroyed all it really did is
destroy the physical form or the object
that houses the power of the Crystal and
so that powers kind of disincorporated
and it's out there but we're basically
told at some future point in time it'll
reform and it'll appear when it needs to
so it's really just kind of Marvel
saying like you'll see this kind of
thing happen right it's like Battlestar
Galactica all of this has happened
before and all of it will happen again
but again that's the nature of the
Avengers forever story is it's basically
cleaning up the continuity of Kang and
immortus Scarlet Centurion iron lad Rama
Tut all that kind of stuff all those
different versions of Kane the Conqueror
that we've seen over the years it's
clearing all that stuff up while at the
same time giving us a pretty interesting
and compelling story but once everything
settles down and once everybody starts
blinking Back The Avengers more or less
say their goodbyes because they all just
kind of go back to their own individual
timelines and the story effectively ends
there but again this is why I say like
this is going to be the storyline that
you see in like Kane Kane Dynasty and
probably Avengers Secret Wars I'm like
99 sure this is what's gonna happen but
let me know what you guys think down in
the comment section thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
purse